[Applause]
again this has nothing to do with the
piece that is not my body they could
have asked to use its probably took a
minute to shoot that I was probably in
the building and they got someone who I
think was about a week from death to uh
and then pasted my head and we connect
we've never been able to figure out who
it is and yelling we can't no one will
tell me who that is it every time we do
this thing I say who is that guy they go
like it's not important and then I say
can we reshoot it with my own body and
they say no we're good we prefer this
guy makes me crazy what's wrong with my
body don't answer that
thanks for backing me up all right well
anyway you hit the info button you get
the information I find out cool stuff
for example I was watching Hollywood
game night yeah that's a good show love
that show and then I hit the button and
it said celebrities pay off their
alimony that was kind of fun
I was watching diners drive-ins and
dives
yeah and then I hit the info button it
said live-action Pokemon character
shouts in-between goats of pastrami
yeah I was watching queer I people love
that show queer I I was watching queer I
and then I hit the button it said over
the course of a week-long makeover
straight men learn what it feels like to
try just to try for the first time I was
watching the crown man oh yeah round
yeah I love the crown and then I hit the
info button and it said historically
accurate except for the tea I'll take
the hit for that one hey master chef
junior I was watching MasterChef junior
yeah working with kids and then it said
hit the button it said host Gordon
Ramsay develops a new face vain while
calling a nine-year-old boy a douche
diver
I was watching Chicago Fire mm-hmm
watching Chicago Fire
hit the button and it said da flames
it's supposed to be stupid watch that's
watching RuPaul's Drag Race RuPaul's
Drag Race yeah RuPaul's Drag Race and
then I hit the button and it said
tonight's episode sponsored by Calvin
Klein penis tuck away tape yeah yeah
Andy and I will tell you that as a very
good product really
I'm wearing it now and finally settle
down everybody
I was watching Fox News yeah then I hit
the button it says what's your president
masturbates to
what is the point Hank
you